Stephen is with us in Maryland hey
Stephen how are you I'm trying to
remember I'm better than I deserve Dave
how about yourself
I understand how can I help so about a
year ago in August of 2018 I signed a
lease with individuals I believed were
longtime friends one of them fell behind
on her rent payments she is the only
other individual besides myself on the
lease we have to authorize residents one
of them moved out at the same time the
roommate on the lease was unable to make
her rent payments and then after talking
to her and trying to help her find a job
she fell five months behind and I kicked
her out but she never removed her name
from police and I was wondering what my
options might be because I know it's
incorrect to think that I'm kind of a
landlord in the situation but the way
that I see it she still owes me for the
rents from January when she moved out to
today because she never removed her name
from bullies well I guess you'd have to
ask a lawyer if you can collect on that
I doubt you can legally I don't know her
and I don't know for sure as a practical
matter the girls broke dude you can't
get money out of a rock you can sue her
into oblivion but it doesn't make her
have money correct and so I mean if you
just want a bankrupt her or something as
vengeance I guess you could but the but
I mean you're not gonna get money as a
result of suing her hmm cuz she and any
money in correct so in that situation
then if I may ask a follow-up do you
think it would be prudent to take a
hardship from my 401k to get my landlord
paid because I'm facing eviction on the
1st of the month
yeah anything
else you're gonna do to get money well
I've picked up a second job I work in
yet services so my regular nine-to-five
alters the hours every week so it's very
difficult quite young do you have do you
have the ability to borrow the money I
do not know okay is your credit bad it
is because I was long baby step two got
reverted back to baby step zero because
I pulled out my savings in order to try
and help the individual who when Italy
so when is this Lisa August of 2020 have
you discussed with the landlord the
ability to get out of it yes I have my
landlord is willing to let me out of the
lease before pursuing legal action so
long as I'm able to find the tenants to
essentially make a new lease with the
tenant or with landlord and then the
landlord will let me out of the least
currently have you been working on that
yes there I have no tenants no tenants
nobody that would pass the background
check that my landlords prefer but he's
not looking for a tenant you are that is
correct sir yes okay
can you borrow on the for oh well now
the only time I tell people to take
money out of retirement is to avoid
bankruptcy or foreclosure and this is
the equivalent being evicted so yeah
you're gonna have to take that my other
401k if you can't borrow it if you can
borrow it on a credit card or something
I do that before I'd cash out a 401k
you're already in debt by five months
I'm not telling you to get a win to dad
I'm telling you get a different kind of
debt to pay this debt off see what I'm
saying yes there so Dave Ramsey's not
telling you to go borrow money I'm
telling you go remove this landlord debt
onto a credit card if you can if you
could go apply the local credit union
work something out anything you can do
but yeah you got to cash out the 401k
because you're gonna be in the street
and you're suing her going after her is
gonna be honestly you're not if you got
money it'd be two years from now
probably and you're probably not gonna
see any money because she doesn't have
money she wasn't contrary she was broke
right yes sir okay how old are you
I'm 28 sir okay so the bad news is
you've gone through all this the good
news is you have the rest of your life
to never have another roommate that you
count on to make payments yes that's the
way I'm looking at it you've completely
learned this lesson thoroughly I hope oh
and then some sir yeah okay and then I
guess you've got to get some other
roommates or get a new tenant or both
between now and August or you're gonna
be right back in the soup aren't you yes
sir
my my general plan has been to try to
not break the lease but get out of the
lease work out a payment plan with my
landlord when I was on baby steps ooh I
canceled the only two credit cards that
I had and I'm working on payments for
those so I'm not sure I know I won't be
in the house comes the 15th of November
oh really yes sir
but you're gonna be on the hook for the
leash I believe so sir yes okay so what
are you you're gonna go into debt on
that again or what I understand oh no
there I'm trying to work out a payment
plan with my landlords get out and then
work with her and pay the fees of
advertising for the what's it called for
the advertising for people to come and
view the house and I've also worked out
a payment with my landlords to be
essentially kind of a handyman during
the interim as the house is being
unoccupied but you're still on the hook
for the ring yes sir I do believe so
FAFSA up to the 15th of November after
the 15th of November I will no longer be
on the hook for the rest oh the
landlord's gonna let you go yes sir oh
great okay absolutely think yeah well
he's also sick of you people okay very
cool good good man that's great you're
free you're not evicted you've paid your
bill and you're gonna have to have a
little money to get into the next place
and you're working six jobs and you're
gonna turn this around and this time
you're going to just move into some
super super cheap then you can cover by
yourself right hopefully the DC suburbs
is a bit expensive that makes it
difficult hopefully you've learned your
lesson and you don't go back into this
so if you want to figure out a way to
Gresham eyes getting right back into
this then I'm questioning your sanity